okay oh another frat party yeah i like
that oh
yeah who is this it's steven what's his
name randolph in the middle down there
this is a king at her stinger hey theo
hey brandon i've got a king of the
stinger for you
themed birthday parties it's my 25th
birthday party
we're going to toga party king it or
sing it
oh damn oh that's hard i like that see
now first of all
this kind of stuff needs to happen more
often i think with the chicks
i agree i agree i don't know maybe we
should bring them into the culture
corner
yeah that looks funny we're not bringing
women into a corner
at this time
right but let's bring them into an open
area we'll make a cultural open
area that's fair sorry but yeah it does
it shouldn't we got to change
culture college culture couch
and i think that name's taken on new
porn you can't have that the culture
lounge
boom culturally lady friendly
doesn't sound yeah it's too you want to
come over to our lounge
full of culture oh that sounds exotic
that sounds nice
it does actually yeah yeah it's
something it's not a bad name for a
comedy club the culture lounge
yeah pretty good the same black club the
ceo yeah the ceo
i'm going to king toga parties yeah
hell yeah now i'm sure everyone there i
what state is that in i'm sure everybody
got corona which isn't a big deal
because they're young but
could be fun they did not say i don't
know
you're still worried about that email
yeah you think it's gonna ruin your
career what are you thinking here
i don't really have that much of a
career but
you got a haircut huh that was he kept
it himself
yeah he's his own barber i didn't do
this one that well though the other side
is clean ah they're both pretty good
actually it looks pretty good
i'd let you come here can you oh he got
hair it'd be weird though i think it'd
be weird
me and brendan talked about maybe
cutting his hair but then actually
imagining me cutting his hair
putting my hand on his head a little
weird
i mean what don't put your hand on his
head just cut it you have to here you
have like a barber
you gotta wear a gl yeah maybe wear a
glove or where uh you know wrap your
hand inside
can you can you deal with long hair can
deal with i do all hair i could do even
alex's hair hold on now what do you mean
even yeah what are you talking about
hair from the bible yeah we do ari's
hair
hairs a little get a little curly malix
oh that's crazy you guys do have similar
hair huh yeah we both have brothers yeah
i got i'm have
yeah you guys are like bible
from the bible right ari and malik yeah
oh that is
very biblical names i don't know where
mine is does it
r means lion it means lion and jew
hebrew lying about what
anything like this lying about the
safety of his van
already brought this lady to the comedy
store sorry man
but there's a little more room what is
this about to be there's a little more
room under this bus
remember that girl you brought to the
comedy store that the cops came in you
heard about that
what do you mean yeah i think he made a
whole video about it
the cops came to pick the girl up well
so i was talking this girl on the
internet
like i do oh like i do from time to time
like we all do let's be real here
oh yeah like everyone here does she's in
trouble for it all right
she's not underage i like what she's
doing so she met me at the comedy store
patio for a glass of wine
and then when she gets there she
explains to me that she is a lady of the
night
she's a pro she's a pro and i didn't
realize that and you had no idea
no idea and she was also very drunk when
she got there okay
she started trying to make out with me
hell yeah as well as
some other comedians that were on the
patio she was just a very social young
lady
social butterfly yeah she was lovely
nice kind so i decided to go hide in the
kitchen in the back and
stay away from this person because it
scared you because i didn't want to be
associated with it
but i also didn't have the courage to
kick her out did you make out with her
at all
i can't remember i can't remember yeah
wow so i went to the kitchen and then as
i'm in the kitchen
she proceeds to cause a bigger scene and
get more drunk
on the patio on the patio curtis the
security guard comes
tackles her she calls him the n-word and
bites them
cops calm and he's white he's white yeah
yeah
so wow i'm gonna use the n word but if i
do
i know how to use it and she went and
she was she does too
she was white yeah she was white so the
cops come and as the cops are arresting
her in handcover she goes where's
arie where is arya i'm here with ari and
i'm just hiding the kitchen i don't know
what
that lady i don't know who that is
meanwhile five other aries who are
attorneys in los angeles
that happened to be on the porch showed
up and gave her their business
and uh yeah i had to make an apology
video to the comedy store staff
and a few others but i'm sure people
forget we have yeah do we have that
video
please do the video's pretty good used
to have it right
uh it's somewhere was she an attractive
young lady yeah she was yeah she was
cute
weird wow she was cute and she was
dropped and i hope she was doing better
i hope that she got her alcoholism under
check and i wish you're nothing but the
best and probably don't drop the n-bomb
you know yeah
yeah i hope she's less racist now